voilà je vous remercie
monsieur Riedinger et Madame Gaspard
donc d'avoir répondu présent à notre
invitation donc nous continuons cet
après-midi nous édition en vous recevant
vous êtes rédacteur du rapport de la
plateforme d'experts pour la rénovation
énergétique des logements en France
Monsieur ruddinger vous êtes le
coordinateur pour les questions de
transition énergétique à l'Institut du
développement durable et des relations
internationales lidli depuis l'année
dernière mais vous avez rejoint
l'Institut il y a 12 ans en tant que
chercheur sur les questions d'énergie et
de climat vos travaux portent notamment
sur la gouvernance des politiques
climatiques en France et sur les enjeux
de la transition énergétique depuis 2020
vous coordonnez également la plateforme
des experts sur la rénovation
énergétique en France en partenariat
étroit avec l'ADEME que nous avons
auditionné la semaine dernière nous vous
recevons donc avec vos deux casquettes
je précise que vous êtes aussi chargé
d'enseignement à Sciences Po Paris et à
suparo Toulouse madame Gaspard vous
pilotez depuis un peu plus de 5 ans la
réflexion prospective de l'ADEME sur le
bâtiment et l'immobilier vous étiez
auparavant au sein de l'agence
sociologue des comportements en matière
d'énergie et de bâtiments après avoir
été chargé de mission sur des questions
de concertation vous avez également été
consultante à Londres il y a une
quinzaine d'années sur les questions
d'impact socio-économique de changement
climatique et de planification
urbaine vous avez tous les deux rédigé
je l'ai dit le rapport de la plateforme
d'experts pour la rénovation énergétique
des logements en France
intitulés réussir le pari de la
rénovation énergétique et ce rapport a
été publié en mai 2022
c'est ce travail qui a motivé votre
audition même si chacun d'entre vous a
réalisé de nombreuses autres recherches
autour du thème de la rénovation des
bâtiments vous pourrez bien entendu
sortir du cadre de ce rapport pour nous
faire partager vos analyses la
plateforme d'experts pour la rénovation
énergétique des logements souligne que
malgré son abord consensuel la politique
de rénovation énergétique des logements
français ne parvient pas à atteindre ces
objectifs et se demande quels sont les
blocages sous-jacents et comment surtout
pouvoir les dépasser vos interrogations
sont donc proches de ceux de notre
commission d'enquête
votre rapport relève un ensemble de
controverses autour de ce sujet
controverse souvent liées aux objectifs
même de la politique de rénovation et
qui sont génératrices de tension la
première de ces tensions résulte de la
cohabitation entre la poursuite
d'objectifs climatiques selon une
logique de décarbonation et la poursuite
d'objectifs énergétique autour d'une
logique d'amélioration de l'efficacité
énergétique et d'isolation la deuxième
tension participe de la poursuite
d'objectifs sociaux au sein de la
politique de rénovation en effet vous
vous interrogez dans les termes suivants
faut-il privilégier la massification des
gestes de travaux les plus rentables
ciblées sur les ménages modestes pour
lutter rapidement contre la précarité
énergétique faut-il ensuite cibler les
aides publiques sur les ménages modestes
uniquement ou fournir également des
aides généreuses pour les classes
moyennes et aisées en mesure d'investir
plus rapidement et massivement afin de
structurer rapidement le marché des
rénovations performantes ce sont là des
questions fondamentales vous déplorez
également que les politiques mises en
oeuvre sur la politique d'urbanisme
politique de rénovation urbaine d'accès
au logement et d'amélioration de
l'habitat fonctionnent le plus souvent
en silo avec des objectifs des acteurs
et des logiques d'action différents bien
qu'ayant comme point commun le même
objet physique à savoir le logement
chacune de ces politiques l'aborde sous
des angles différents ce constat plaide
pour une plus grande coordination de la
gouvernance des politiques de rénovation
énergétiques vous constatez ensuite
d'autres types de controverses davantage
lié aux outils de mise en oeuvre de la
politique de rénovation la viabilité
économique et financière des travaux de
rénovation l'approche globale ou par
étape de la rénovation le point
d'équilibre entre incitation et
obligation ou encore la structuration de
l'offre qui implique une stratégie pour
le secteur du bâtiment filière
professionnelle dont l'offre doit être
en capacité d'absorber la hausse massive
de la demande avec bien sûr un niveau de
qualification élevé dans ce contexte
quelle feuille de route proposez-vous
pour le futur de la rénovation
énergétique des logements comment
articuler les deux principes directeurs
que vous proposez à savoir d'une part
l'accélération et d'autre part la
performance dans quel sens faire évoluer
les dispositifs existants et quel
nouveau dispositif
faut-il mettre en place avant de vous
laisser la parole pour répondre à ses
premières questions il me reviennent de
vous indiquer que cette audition est
diffusée en direct et en différé sur le
site internet du Sénat et qu'un
compte-rendu sera publié je dois
également vous rappeler qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête serait passible des peines
prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14 et
434-15 du code pénal qui peuvent aller
de trois ans à 7 ans d'emprisonnement et
de 45000 euros à 100000 euros d'amende
je vous invite donc madame monsieur a
prêté serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité a levé la main droite
et à dire je ne jure
je vous en remercie donc on vous laisse
la parole pour une quinzaine de minutes
et ensuite le rapporteur mais aussi les
membres de la commission qui sont
présents à cette audition vous poseront
certainement d'autres questions merci à
vous
merci beaucoup
merci la présidence merci monsieur le
rapporteur
merci aux autres membres pour pour
l'invitation à présenter nos travaux
alors je vais prendre le une première
partie de notre exposé de préliminaires
pour vous parler un peu de du cadrage
de ces travaux là et comment ça
présenter donc deux des controverses que
vous allez mentionné sachant que là on
va essayer de vous en donner un aperçu
de 5 qui nous semble essentiels et on
pourra évidemment revenir sur les autres
vous l'avez dit madame la Présidente
ce qui a ce qui nous a amené en fait à
créer cette plateforme d'experts et à
faire ses travails là c'est un consensus
de départ de se dire à première vue les
politiques de rénovation énergétique
sont parfaitement consensibles
aujourd'hui c'est un enjeu qui
partageait de façon transpartisane au
niveau politique avec des objectifs
extrêmement ambitieux et pourtant pour
tous ceux comme vous qui suivent ces
sujets depuis plus d'une dizaine
d'années on se rend compte qu'en fait on
a du mal à avancer atteindre nos
objectifs
et que malgré ses consensus en fait il y
a des blocages qui qu'on a parfois du
mal à identifier et donc pour nous le
point de départ de ce travail a été
vraiment de se dire est-ce qu'on arrive
à faire une cartographie des
controverses politiques qui parfois ne
sont pas rendu explicite en tant que tel
mais qui peuvent présenter autant de
points de blocage pour avancer et qu'il
faut justement arriver à mettre au coeur
du débat et à dépasser donc nous
l'objectif de ce travail il était
vraiment là sachant que dépasser une
controverse ne veut pas forcément dire
amener un consensus parfait il peut y
avoir des divergences de point de vue
c'est parfaitement normal mais elle ne
doivent pas forcément empêcher l'action
donc c'était ça un peu le sens de ce
travail qu'on a mené pendant deux ans
avec une vingtaine d'experts Vénus à la
fois du monde de la recherche des
bureaux d'études d'agence public voilà
et d'autres experts mais vraiment pour
essayer d'avoir pas mal de points de vue
différents
on avait également un constat qui est
partagé on va pas trop insister
là-dessus parce que vous le connaissez
par cœur mais de retard face à des
objectifs extrêmement ambitieux au
niveau national
et vous vous l'évoquiez tout à l'heure
l'enjeu aujourd'hui c'est comment
arriver à concilier les forces
d'accélération
des rénovations énergétiques de
massification quelque part avec l'effort
d'approfondissement donc d'une meilleure
performance
et la Bonne Nouvelle aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on a peut-être déjà fait la moitié du
chemin
puisque quelque part en termes
d'accélération les résultats sont plutôt
très encourageants avec aujourd'hui dans
les 700 000 gestes de rénovation réalisé
par an
donc c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle par
contre derrière en terme
d'approfondissement clairement on a un
gros enjeu sur la performance atteinte
des rénovations donc on est entre 40 à
60 000 rénovations performantes par an à
peu près sachant que on est sur quelque
chose qui est extrêmement dur à suivre
mais je pense qu'elle observatoire
national de la rénovation énergétique A
du volant
autre élément important en termes de
bilan selon les chiffres de
l'Observatoire National le gain moyen
par projet de rénovation se situe
aujourd'hui autour de 3600 kWh
qui si on prend un logement parfaitement
moyen du parc 91 mètres carrés 180 190
kWh par mètre carré en consommation
voudrait dire à peu près un gain de
performance de 20%. par contre si on
applique ces mêmes volumes d'économie
d'énergie à une passoire thermique on
est plutôt de l'ordre de 10%
donc c'est clairement pas suffisant par
rapport à l'objectif d'amener le
l'ensemble du parc au niveau BBC
et tout ça évidemment un coup ce retard
dans la mise en oeuvre des politiques
nous on l'avait évoqué dans un article
de blog qu'on a publié également l'été
dernier sur la rénovation énergétique
comme levier de sortie de la crise
énergétique où on avait notamment
signalé que
si la France avait atteint les objectifs
fixés pendant le Grenelle de
l'environnement de 2008 en matière de
Renault et énergétique à savoir réduire
de 38% la consommation d'énergie dans
les bâtiments atteindre 500 millions à
100 performantes par an on aurait plus
été dépendant du gaz russe depuis 2020
donc ça montre quand même l'importance
de la rénovation énergétique en termes
de résilience pas uniquement sur le plan
climatique mais également géopolitique
économique
autre élément important en termes de
coût du retard encore une fois liée à la
crise de l'énergie
vous connaissez l'important coût du
bouclier tarifaire qui a été mise en
place pour apprendre à l'urgence sociale
économique de cette crise
donc qui a consommé environ 30 milliards
d'euros de dépenses publiques en 2022
jusqu'à 45 milliards d'euros budgétaires
en 2023 à comparer aux 3 milliards
d'euros de budget pour ma prime rénov
donc on est en rapport de 1 à 10 qui
pose évidemment des questions sur la
gestion de la crise parce que l'enjeu
par rapport aux crises futures
évidemment d'améliorer notre résidence
pour en venir au controverse la première
qu'on avait abordé dans l'étude qui
aujourd'hui est vraiment central je
pense pour vos travaux et dans la mise
en oeuvre des politiques de renovation
énergétique c'est celle qui qui oppose
apparemment une logique de décarbonation
et logique d'efficacité
ce qu'on avait noté dans nos travaux
c'est qu'en fait cette controverse est
directement lié à deux autres
controverses
l'une sur la faisabilité technique et la
pertinence économique des rénovations
performantes qui continuent à faire
débat et tant qu'on n'arrive pas quelque
part à débloquer à clarifier cette
controverse là on a beaucoup de mal à
avancer sur celle entre des
carbonatations efficaces énergétique et
l'autre sur le point d'arrivée c'est à
dire sur les la vision du parc de
logement dans les scénarios prospectives
à l'horizon 2050 et ce qui nous raconte
quelque part sur la possibilité à
atteindre la neutralité carbone en
jouant uniquement sur la décarbonation
de l'énergie plutôt que l'isolation
alors ce qu'il faut bien noter
aujourd'hui c'est quand théorie dans le
dans la stratégie politique de la France
cette controverse a déjà été dépassée
puisque l'objectif BBC en 2050 figure
dans dans le code de l'énergie et que le
plan de rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments 2018
indiquaient noirceur blanc l'objectif de
rénovation de l'ensemble du parc de
bâtiments au niveau Bâtiment Basse
Consommation d'ici 2050 ne pourra être
confirmée voire renforcé on insistant
qui en fait c'était quelque part la clé
pour pouvoir décarboner ensuite
et que derrière ce qu'on note également
sur les controverses autour des
objectifs il ne faut pas oublier que la
Renault synergétique on n'a pas commencé
à la faire uniquement dans une visée de
décarbonation il y a d'autres objectifs
comme poursuit quand on parle de
performance des logements que ça soit la
question de l'obsolescence face
notamment aux impacts du changement
climatique la question de la précarité
énergétique qui n’oublie pas forcément
au même règle que celle de la
décordation et que justement il faut
voir beaucoup plus large si on ces
questions là
dans ce contexte là on a également un
point de vigilance assez important de ne
pas succomber aux solutions qui
pourraient un peu trop simple pour être
vrai notamment l'idée qu'on pourrait
tout simplement mettre des pompes à
chaleur un peu partout et que ça
résoudrait tous nos problèmes de façon
un peu magique attention également au
risque de déplacer l'effort de
décarbonation parce que qui dit je
résous la question dans le secteur des
bâtiments en misant sur encore plus de
production d'énergie décarbonée ça veut
dire mécaniquement je crois la pression
en matière de décarbonation sur le
secteur énergie
et on a forcément des limites là dessus
attention également par rapport au fait
qu'aujourd'hui
le cadre des objectifs 2030 et en train
d'être renforcé dans le contexte du
programme afin du projet fit for fifty
five européen donc pour l'instant on a
un objectif de réduction de 50 % des
émissions dans le secteur des bâtiments
d'ici 2030 qui a priori va encore être
renforcé et qui va mettre encore plus
l'accent sur la décarbonation donc c'est
vraiment dans ce contexte là qu'il faut
pas perdre de vue
cette idée de massification des
rénovations performantes encore une fois
pour répondre à l'ensemble des objectifs
j'enchaîne très rapidement sur la
deuxième controverse qui est centrale
qui est sur la question de la
rentabilité
des renoies énergétiques
je vais pas pouvoir vous donner un
chiffre magique sur ce que coûte ou
rapporte une rénovation énergétique mais
plutôt
[Musique]
porter à votre attention l'importance
justement de ne pas regarder les
résultats des études économiques parce
que vous verrez de tout j'imagine vous
l'avez déjà vu y compris dans les
interventions dans les auditions
certains vont vous dire que les
rénovations performantes représentent un
optimum économique à long terme en
tenant compte de l'ensemble des
objectifs à atteindre d'autres vous
disent mais en fait non ça marche pas
que ça rapporte très peu quelle est
durée d'amortissement sans supérieur à
30 ans etc et donc nous notre message
quelque part par rapport à ça c'est
avant tout l'importance de mieux
regarder et mettre en discussion les
questions méthodologiques et les
hypothèses qui sont utilisées donc dans
l'étude vous trouverez pas mal
d'exemples notamment sur
l'importance de regarder les périmètres
de coûts et de bénéfices qui sont
considérés dans différentes études
certains vont s'intéresser vraiment
uniquement à la rentabilité financière
directe des travaux pour le ménage
d'autres vont également essayer de
chiffrer les gains en matière de confort
de valorisation du patrimoine de
bénéfices pour la santé publique etc
donc vraiment important de regarder ces
différents périmètres de cou et de
bénéfice également de voir que les
études n'ont pas forcément les mêmes
objectifs
certains vont s'intéresser à ce qui
représente l'optimum en termes
d'efficacité économique pour l'État pour
les politiques publiques d'autres qui
vont s'intéresser vraiment à la question
de la rentabilité au niveau des ménages
nous la proposition qu'on fait pour
dépasser cette controverse c'est
d'arrêter de parler de rentabilité
financière parce qu'au final les ménages
aujourd'hui ne réfléchissent pas en
termes de rentabilité financière par
contre ce qui veut pas dire qu'ils ont
que le paramètre économique n'est pas
essentiel mais nous en propose discipls
situé une océan qui serait un peu plus
large qui est celle de des conditions de
viabilité économique des travaux de
rénovation dans la viabilité économique
en met différents critères
on met notamment le critère d'équilibre
entre trésorerie beaucoup plus important
pour les ménages aujourd'hui donc
qu'est-ce qui change pour leur flux de
trésorerie avant après les travaux
deuxième enjeu essentiel la solvabilité
donc c'est bien d'avoir des prêts à taux
préférentiels ou à taux zéro mais pour
des ménages déjà très endettés est-ce
que c'est une solution ou pas et comment
est-ce qu'on trouve des mécanismes de
financement alternatif
et également un autre élément qui est
très peu considéré dans les dispositifs
politiques aujourd'hui qui est celui de
la perception des risques et de la
garantie de réalisation de garantie de
qualité des travaux
donc quelque part qui pose des questions
de mutualisation des risques de tiers de
confiance qui pourrait également assurer
ce risque à la place des ménages
donc tout ça pour vraiment encourager à
quelque part exiger une meilleure
transparence sur la méthodologie des
études économiques de faire également
attention au fait que beaucoup d'études
économétriques ne vont pas préciser quel
type de rénovation énergétique est-ce
qu'on regarde on a au final très très
peu de retours d'expérience en France
sur le bilan économique de rénovation
performante et que beaucoup d'études ne
nous disent pas que la rénovation
énergétique intrinsèquement ne serait
pas rentable que ça soit pour l'État ou
pour le ménage mais qu'elle nous disent
quelque part que les outils politiques
sont déployés aujourd'hui ne sont pas
efficaces
voilà donc il faut bien faire la
différence entre les deux dernier
élément qu'on apporte par rapport à ça
c'est
l'importance de voir la question
économique dans une vision dynamique
pour ne pas uniquement regarder vers le
passé en disant aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
possible ce n'est pas rentable mais
justement quel serait les conditions qui
demain permettrait d'assurer la
viabilité économique au sens large des
rénovations performantes et ainsi de les
massifier
alors je vais prendre le relais pour
vous brosser les trois dernières grandes
controverse qu'on a trouvées dans ce
travail donc la troisième controverse
c'est la controverse sur la notion même
de performance performance d'une
rénovation performance d'un logement
donc on a évoqué la notion de la
performance de la rénovation sur le plan
énergétique vous le disez tout à l'heure
on a une pluralité de politique qui ont
pour même objet physique le logement
mais des objectifs très différents alors
on va pas toutes les citer mais il y a
l'adaptation vieillissement bien
évidemment énergie carbone lutte contre
la précarité énergétique mais aussi des
politiques à l'échelle du quartier
régénération des coeurs de ville
rénovation urbaine etc et toutes ces
politiques vont agir avec un objectif
sans forcément prendre en compte les
autres ce qui multiplie finalement les
occasions manquées chacune pourrait
regarder l'autre en considérant que
l'intervention que fait l'autre est une
occasion manquée pour elle-même et donc
on a une multitude d'intervention
publique sur le bâti en France qui
cherche chacune à répondre à un objectif
comment on peut dépasser ça alors on
peut le dépasser déjà on adoptant
explicitement une vision large de la
performance en se disant que quand on
fait la rénovation c'est la rénovation
énergétique c'est la rénovation carbone
mais c'est aussi de la rénovation
d'adaptation au changement climatique de
confort de régénération urbaine etc le
poser explicitement les choses
pourraient permettre à notre avis de
commencer à casser ces silos de
politique publique ensuite arbitrer
identifier les potentiels points de
friction entre ces objectifs alors pour
en donner un exemple
agir contre la précarité énergétique ça
peut vouloir dire des aides ponctuelles
à des travaux d'urgence et effectivement
il faut pouvoir donner à la Rhino dans
la rénovation énergétique ces ADP
ponctuels leur donner une place
puisqu'elles ont une fonction sociale en
objective social pourvu qu'elle soit
conditionnée à des audits énergétiques
qui permettent de mieux comprendre les
travaux mais si on identifie en arbitre
les points potentiels de friction on
peut les dépasser si on les laisse
silencieux
ils deviennent des blocages et troisième
étape alignez le dispositif de politique
publique sur la performance alors quand
on dit aligner les dispositifs de
politique publique si tous les
dispositifs de politique publique on
parle beaucoup d'aligner les aides
financières sur la performance c'est
indispensable mais l'aide financière
n'est pas le seul instrument politique
publique il y a la communication il y a
l'accompagnement qui pourrait devenir
plus multi thématique puisqu'on sait
très bien quand un ménage fait une
rénovation surtout si c'est une
rénovation lourde c'est une fois tous
les 10 15 ans et qu'il en profite pour
faire plein de choses dans son logement
pas seulement de l'énergie donc en
résumé sur cette controverse à chaque
fois qu'on agit sur un logement on
pourrait se donner comme objectif
d'embarquer l'ensemble de la performance
et donc d'adapter la politique publique
en conséquence et ça ça peut se faire
assez rapidement dès maintenant en
regardant où va l'argent public sur la
rénovation du logement au sens large et
en cherchant ces réorientations
mon troisième controverse quatrième
controverse celle sur les outils ce
match obligation en citation alors on a
d'un côté des tenants du vu l'ampleur de
la tâche on y arrivera pas sans obliger
et puis de l'autre des tenants du mais
on peut pas obligé c'est de l'économie
punitive c'est le chez soi des gens
c'est la propriété privée etc alors pour
dépasser cette controverse que nos
travaux ont mis en évidence premièrement
c'est que les outils ne s'opposent pas
puisque quand on regarde la politique
actuelle on a déjà un mix entre
incitation et obligation donc on n'est
pas sur une opposition on est plutôt sur
quel est le bon le bon point d'équilibre
entre entre ces outils
et ce qu'on a également montré c'est que
finalement ce qui compte ce n'est pas
tant la nature de l'outil mais sa force
et ça et la crédibilité du signal qu'il
envoie aux acteurs parce que on peut
trouver des incitations qui sont fortes
bien conçues qui fonctionnent bien ou
des incitations faibles qui sont mal
calibrées et de la même façon on peut
avoir des obligations qui sont fortes si
elles sont accompagnées si elles sont
contrôlées si elles sont sanctionnées et
de l'autre côté des obligations pardon
qui sont faibles si elles ne le sont pas
et un exemple d'obligation faible dans
le bâtiment c'est l'obligation de
travaux embarquer lors du ravalement en
copropriété qui est une obligation qui
sur le papier devrait permettre de faire
énormément de rénovation dans les faits
on en a pas de suivi à notre
connaissance peu de sanctions ce qui
fait qu'on a une obligation un outil là
qui nous permettrait d'agir mais qui qui
les conditions ne sont pas réunies pour
qu'ils puissent porter porter ses fruits
donc finalement c'est vraiment la force
la crédibilité du signal qui qui est
important et ça ça repose sur la qualité
de la conception des outils et donc un
point qu'on peut mettre en avant pour
l'action dans les dans les mois à venir
c'est d'améliorer les processus de
conception des outils de politique
publique et notamment d'évaluation
excentée qui à l'heure actuelle sont
plutôt des processus assez légers et
qu'on pourrait largement améliorer donc
c'est difficile de répondre à cette
question du point d'équilibre entre
incitation et obligations en l'absence
finalement de réel évaluation et santé
et donc dans les prix priorités il nous
semble que on a deux grands sujets à
venir premièrement l'évaluation excentée
de l'obligation à la mutation
en essayant de regarder quels sont les
impacts en termes énergétique mais aussi
les impacts en termes de marché
immobilier puisque dès qu'on va aller
sur une obligation on est sur des
grandes masses et donc on va avoir un
impact sur le marché immobilier savoir
quel était impact à l'heure actuelle
personne à notre connaissance n'est en
capacité de le dire donc si on doit
avoir des instruments de grande ampleur
il faut avoir l'évaluation qui va avec
et puis deuxième priorité le suivi de la
loi climat résilience parce que
finalement l'interdiction location
dépasseoirs c'est quelque part une forme
d'obligation si on a juste le symétrique
et là aussi il y a un enjeu à faire un
suivi propre de ces
de ces instruments politiques publiques
et puis enfin dernière controverse la
controverse sur la structuration de la
filière professionnelle alors vous nous
avez posé une question en préparation
sur comment est-ce qu'on aide la filière
à ce structurer et innocente que de
notre côté finalement poser cette
question c'est faire un présupposé que
le constat qu'il y a un problème de
structurelation de la filière et
partager or en fait ce qu'on a montré
dans nos travaux c'est que ce constat
n'est pas partagé puisqu'on a d'un côté
des tenants de de représentants qui vont
plutôt dire il manque des ressources
humaines 40 000 rénovations faut passer
à 700 000 etc on a des manques et de
l'autre côté plutôt des représentants
des acteurs professionnels qui disent la
filière c'est toujours adaptée la
filière s'adaptera l'appareil productif
du bâtiment et résilient il a toujours
fait face aux modifications d'activité
et donc du coup pour le dépasser il me
semble que il y a un premier enjeu à
produire un chiffrage partagé avec les
organisations professionnelles et que ce
chiffrage il faut trouver la bonne façon
de le faire pour permettre à ces
organisations professionnelles de faire
valoir leur point de vue mais également
d'écouter celui des autres et puis ce
chiffrage il doit concerner l'ensemble
des métiers de la rénovation pas
seulement les travaux puisque finalement
la rénovation ça va être aussi
énormément de services de
l'accompagnement de du contrat de
garantie de performance et donc de
l'assurance etc toute cette matière
grise il faut aussi pouvoir le planifier
parce que il va y avoir des besoins en
main d'oeuvre extrêmement important et
finalement tout ce que ça ça dessine
finalement c'est une nouvelle filière
industrielle de la rénovation il y a un
potentiel de poids économique de sa
filière particulièrement important c'est
un secteur qui a une forte valeur
ajoutée au niveau local un secteur dont
la productivité
a peut évolué sur ces 30 dernières
années donc on a là un secteur à fort
potentiel et ce serait vraiment à notre
sens une opportunité de d'inscrire la
rénovation dans la stratégie d'industrie
verte de la France pour en faire
vraiment un des piliers de la stratégie
industrielle
donc en conclusion ce que nos travaux
ont montré pour faire écho à une de vos
questions c'est la nécessité d'une
programmation plus réelle qui ferait
plusieurs
qui répondrai à plusieurs objectifs
premièrement organiser le changement
d'échelle en mettant en cohérence les
besoins et les ressources alors besoin
et ressources sur quoi sur des
dimensions clés sur le financement vous
avez auditionné nos collègues dayforcy
sur les ressources humaines etc
identifier les grandes dimensions clés
sur lequel il faut que offre = demande
deuxièmement organiser une gouvernance
qui permet d'expliciter dépasser les
controverses et les silos de politiques
publiques troisièmement intégrer un
travail de fond d'évaluation à la fois
excenté pour pouvoir concevoir des
politiques efficaces mais aussi expost
et puis enfin organise les décisions qui
sont sans regret à prendre là maintenant
à court terme et on peut en citer trois
l'alignement des aides financières sur
la performance l'évaluation excentée de
l'obligation à la mutation et la
structuration de la filière
merci
merci beaucoup pour cette présentation
certes synthétique mais déjà bien
précise de vos travaux dont je laisse la
parole à notre rapporteur
merci merci madame la Présidente merci
beaucoup pour vos explications et puis
pour le
système que vous mettez en place qui est
assez important en tout cas à la fois
d'évaluation et puis sur ce principe de
controverse en fait mon magasin elle est
assez simple c'est peut-être de
justement par rapport à ces ouais c'est
ça 5 contre Hertz que vous avez pu
balayer et avec du coup ce regard là
par rapport justement au dispositif et
c'est vrai que je vois que les
prédécesseurs juste avant vous disait
que en gros on était à 2023 qu'on était
vraiment un stade de
oui de réflexion
sur justement l'orientation des
politiques publiques en matière de
rénovation thermique donc tout l'intérêt
à la fois de du travail qu'on est en
train de faire et puis de ce que vous
avez pu de ce que vous avez vu produire
mais peut-être justement à travers vous
vous réflexions qu'est-ce qui peut être
justement concrètement par rapport aux
politiques publiques actuelles qu'est-ce
qui qu'est-ce qui vous paraît
fonctionner justement et ne pas
fonctionner
et qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait en tout cas
améliorer ses réponses beaucoup de
questions alors ça peut être rester sur
un système tel qu'il est de
d'aide qui sont apportées et d'aide et
d'aide financière avec un accompagnement
mais c'est vrai qu'on a eu aussi des
propositions de dire on renverse
totalement les choses avec plutôt aller
vers de l'obligation et avec un
dispositif qui pourrait être
oui une obligation mais un reste à
charge zéro avec un dispositif de prêt
sur du long terme etc mais qui
permettent de dire en fait il faut y
aller de
plus beaucoup plus forte en tout cas
alors vous avez dit que c'était un petit
peu les deux mais enfin voilà j'aimerais
bien avoir moi votre votre regard en
fait par rapport à l'analyse que vous
avez et par rapport aux politiques
publiques qui ont été mis en place qui
ont déjà d'ailleurs évolué quand même
assez rapidement et peut-être aussi sur
les dispositifs justement qui qui sont
mis en place et qui ont aussi évolué que
ça soit sur la question du notamment du
DPE
sur la question aussi de la
labellisation des entreprises notamment
avec le RGE et sur la difficulté quand
même qu'on a à voir à travers les
différentes auditions sur
l'évaluation des des travaux et des
réalisations qui sont faites et de leur
performance à la fin c'est à dire que on
fait confiance aux entreprises à travers
un label mais qu'en fait on a très peu
de dispositifs pour vérifier en fait au
final
le la qualité des travaux et les
performances qui sont réellement et
qu'on a qu'on obtient réellement et donc
comment vous voyez aussi ça
en termes de de d'évolution justement
des politiques publiques
je vais essayer de commencer la question
de quelles évolutions concrètes
aujourd'hui est extrêmement difficile
évidemment
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui fonctionne qu'est-ce qui
fonctionne pas je vais pas aborder les
outils ma prime Renault ou autre en
détail je pense que d'autres l'ont fait
mais le regard qu'on a essayé de poser
en termes de gestion de gouvernance des
politiques publiques il est assez simple
qu'est-ce qui fonctionne c'est d'avoir
des cadres crédibles
sur un horizon suffisamment lointain
pour que les acteurs puissent
l'anticiper qu'est-ce qui ne fonctionne
pas c'est d'avoir des politiques
publiques qui changent après année sans
aucune visibilité sans aucun cas et
aujourd'hui il faut bien dire que on est
plutôt dans le deuxième cas c'est à dire
que même si aujourd'hui il y a des des
évolutions plutôt favorables dans les
dispositifs d'aide avec justement cette
volonté d'aller davantage d'avoir une
rénovation performante d'introduire des
obligations nouvelles il n'y a pas de
cap et quand on parle de programmation
pluriannuelle c'est vraiment ce sens là
qu'on lui donne c'est de dire l'outil
qu'on n'a jamais été
capable de produire en ces 15 dernières
années en termes de politique de
renovation énergétique c'est une feuille
de route une programmation qui sur un
horizon de 10 ans
année après année année après année nos
détails
quels vont être les évolutions
structurantes de
mes dispositifs d'aide ma réglementation
mes dispositif d'accompagnement ma
stratégie de filière et d'offre on n'a
jamais fait ça
et dans quelque part le professionnel
qui notamment aujourd'hui critiquent le
fait que ils en peuvent plus et qui ne
souhaitent qu'une chose c'est qu'on les
laisse tranquille on peut les comprendre
parce que notamment avec l'ancien crédit
d'impôts transformation énergétique on a
vraiment eu ces systèmes un pas en avant
de pas en arrière en change les règles
un peu tout le temps il faut absolument
éviter ça et par rapport à votre
question sur quel équilibre entre
incitation et obligations c'est
exactement le même point c'est à dire
que à partir du moment où on arriverait
à vraiment décliner une stratégie
idéalement partagée avec les acteurs qui
vraiment regarde ces éléments année
apranés en mettant les ressources
budgétaires les moyens pour que ça soit
crédible pour l'ensemble des acteurs on
arrive à quelque chose
et c'est un point d'autant plus
important que aujourd'hui et quelque
part on ne peut que le saluer on a une
sorte d'effervescence des travaux autour
des enjeux de renoi sur énergétiques il
y a votre commission bancaire il y a en
parallèle bientôt la publication de la
nouvelle feuille de route des
carbonation des bâtiments il y a le
groupe de travail du Conseil national
fondation que tu dois également rendre
sa copie voilà donc il y a tout un tas
de choses qui sont en cours mais j'ai
personnellement l'impression qu'ils vont
toujours s'arrêter un peu avant c'est à
dire qu'ils vont définir des grands axes
stratégiques aller davantage sur la
rénovation globale augmenter les aides
mais sans décliner sans aller dans ces
niveaux d'opérationnalités qui nous fait
défaut aujourd'hui donc voilà quelque
part pour moi l'enjeu principal sur
lequel il faut agir aujourd'hui
sur le est-ce qu'il faut aller vers
davantage d'aide avec accompagnement ou
des obligations avec reste à charge zéro
les travaux qu'on a mené ils sont assez
clair là-dessus c'est qu'en fait l'un ne
va pas sans l'autre donc en fait des des
aides
très bien structurées justifie bien
davantage des obligations qui vont avec
et une obligation déployer à grande
échelle ne peut exister ne peut être
acceptable qu'à condition de justement
être mis en oeuvre avec les conditions
qui vont avec en termes de financement
et d'accompagnement donc la question
c'est pas quelle équilibre la question
c'est comment est-ce qu'on y arrive
progressivement sur les 10 prochaines
années
sur la structuration de l'offre et la
qualité
c'est exactement ce qu'on mentionné
avant à partir du moment il y a pas
cette feuille de route partagée
[Musique]
il y a eu un rapport de l'Inspection
générale des finances en 2017 qui a dit
oui oui c'est parfaitement pertinent
mais en fait on va pas y arriver
pourquoi parce qu'on a pas les experts
thermiciens les tiers de confiance qui
nous permettrait d'évaluer la qualité
des travaux donc tant qu'on a pas cette
programmation qui nous dit certes on
peut jouer éternellement à au dilemme de
la poule et de l’œuf et de dire ben non
il n'y arrive pas
mais il faut un jour dire en fait il y
aura des choses qui vont arriver à
partir de 2030 toutes les aides vont
être conditionnées à une évaluation expo
ce qui veut dire qui est d'ici là il
faut qu'on arrive à structurer une
filière de 5000 experts carniciens qui
évaluent les travaux donc d'où
l'importance de vraiment réfléchir en
termes de programmation
peut-être juste pour compléter
effectivement sur cette organisation de
la phase de transition c'est peut-être
ça à 2030 qui est le plus difficile à
faire pour sortir des chiffres qu'on a à
l'heure actuelle et monter en puissance
on est sur des courbes qui sont
extrêmement importantes dans les
scénarios tous les scénarios prospectifs
on a des chiffres 2030 de 700 000
rénovations en moyenne par an 40 000 à
700 000 on est sur des phases très
importantes et finalement cette phase de
transition personne a encore vraiment
décrit à quoi elle ressemble
quel type d'acteurs on va avoir besoin
et de combien on va avoir besoin de quel
type d'acteur on va avoir besoin en 2025
en 2026 en 2027 ce qui fait que quand on
pense des
des dispositifs de type accompagnement
qui sont par nature des dispositifs à
massifier on a du mal à trouver du monde
pour le faire parce que on n'a pas
anticipé le fait qu'il nous faudrait du
monde et effectivement c'est un système
de poulet et d'oeuf mais tant qu'on a
pas résolu le problème de la
programmation on aura toujours ce
dispositif donc effectivement cette
cette question est extrêmement
importante comment on organise la phase
de transition sur juste sur la question
de l'évaluation de la performance c'est
des choses qui existent déjà dans le
tertiaire sur tout ce qui est contrat de
performance énergétique donc on peut
imaginer
transposer c'est à dire que les outils
les méthodes la philosophie existent
déjà maintenant il faut l'adapter il
faut l'adapter à des ménages il faut
l'adapter etc mais on n'est pas loin de
savoir et de pouvoir le faire donc ça
fait partie des choses sur lesquelles la
dame travaille
et on aura des financements associés à
ça mais donc on est vraiment pas loin de
pouvoir le faire et on pense que pouvoir
enfin positionner cette garantie de
performance dans la phase de transition
se dire à échéance de 4,5 ans on se rend
en capacité de d'avoir cette garantie de
performance et donc du coup on entraîne
la filière et on envoie un signal clair
à la filière par ce biais là nous paraît
extrêmement intéressant et pour revenir
désolée sur la question aussi des aides
financières
l'aide à deux fonctions soit elle incite
soit elle solvabilise
si on n'a pas si on a un dispositif
d'obligation ça veut pas dire qu'on a
plus besoin d'aide parce qu'en fait on a
toujours besoin de voir l'aide le côté
de l'être qui solvabilise donc il faut
pas imaginer qu'un dispositif
d'obligation coûtera moins cher en fait
c'est juste que l'aide elle viendra
aider les ménages qui sont en phase
d'une obligation mais ils font pas les
moyens de le faire donc dans tous les
cas on sera sur des montants
d'investissement important
est-ce que nos collègues ont des
questions à poser
non oui Franck montoger juste une petite
remarque pour pour sourire
d'étendre l'atmosphère qui n'est pas
tendue merci Madame ma présidente ce que
vous ne dire dans le domaine qui le
vôtre vous aime beaucoup d'autres
domaines quand je vous entends parler de
d'éval d'étude d'impact vous avez parlé
de l'évaluation santé etc c'est ça quoi
c'est la manière
finalement c'est la gouvernance publique
dans tous les domaines où il y a un peu
de parfois beaucoup de complexité voilà
alors vous avez dans votre propos qui
était très intéressant vous avez vous
êtes placé me semble-t-il du point de
vue
de l'État voilà de la de la conduite de
la définition de la conduite la gestion
des politiques publiques dans ce dans ce
sujet on l'a vu à l'occasion d'autres
auditions il n'y a pas que il y a pas
que l'État tout seul il y a évidemment
les échelons infra infra-nationaux que
sont les régions les départements les
communautés de communes etc
voilà alors ça rajoute de la complexité
évidemment à ce que vous avez déjà
exposé mais comment cette dimension là
finalement territoriale du sujet
voulait intégrer dans votre réflexion
parce que vous n'en avez pas parlé
nous sommes utile j'ai peut-être été
distrait mais je crois pas
alors effectivement on en a pas parlé
alors je pense qu'il est hors de notre
périmètre de conseiller sur le bon
niveau de gouvernance de la rénovation
énergétique mais par contre pointer sur
le fait que l'échelon local a sur ces 30
dernières années étaient un terreau
d'innovation particulièrement important
on aurait pas fait le BBC en région si
on n'avait pas eu des régions pionnières
comme la Normandie qui se sont engagés
là on a des des territoires qui vont
donner des aides sur le biosourcer etc
donc il y a il y a une pépinière
d'innovation dans le local qu'il faut
absolument prendre en compte ce qui veut
dire qu'il faut lui laisser la
possibilité d'innover ce qui veut pas
dire qu'il faut du coup que le ménage
soit confronté à une diversité trop
importante ce qui ce qu'il a à l'heure
actuelle donc il y a à la fois
cette innovation qu'il faut qu'il faut
laisser qu'il faut porter et qu'il faut
et qu'il faut aider et puis ensuite et
ça c'est un autre principe d'innovation
en politique publique qui nous tient à
cœur c'est de dessiner l'action publique
pour qu'elle soit le plus simple
possible pour pour le ménage et donc
finalement il y a un défi d'évaluation
avec santé mais il y a aussi un déficit
de design de politique publique dans les
dans les politiques à l'heure actuelle
c'est à dire que il y a très peu de
dispositifs qui permettent de tester
l'outil de politique publique
l'interface de politique publique qu'on
conçoit et qui répond à des à des
contraintes qui sont celles du
concepteur de la politique publique de
la tester
avec des vrais gens qui représentent la
diversité de la cible de la politique
publique et si on avait plus de
dispositifs de design de politique
publique qui permettent en fait
d'ajuster on se rendrait compte que
avoir 12 formulaires c'est pas gérable
mais il y a plein d'autres trucs qui
sont pas gérables dans le parcours d'un
ménage sur la rénovation il y a des
ruptures d'information etc donc du coup
pour être sûr de comprendre
vous en appelez à des démarches
conceptuelles
en matière de politique publique sur un
sujet comme celui-là comparable à ce
qu'on a en matière de mise au point de
produits quelconque
voilà de je sais plus comment ça
s'appelle des tests
à la fois sur le qualitatif le
quantitatif le ressenti le truc le
machin la couleur le goût non mais pour
comparer c'est ça c'est ça que pour être
sûr
on pourrait dire qu'il y a peut-être
plus de design qui passe dans le yaourt
que vous allez acheter que dans la dans
le dispositif de politique publique
auquel vous êtes confronté parce qu'il y
a des acteurs qui ont besoin nous vendre
leur yaourts alors que le dispositif de
politique publique peut vivre sans qu'on
y est recours ça c'est un petit peu pour
pour participatif au stade de la
conception ou de la révision de
l'adaptation des politiques publiques
qui concernent directement les gens en
question quoi voilà donc les citoyen
c'est ça il existe tout un tas de
méthodologies qui qui existent qui ont
été par exemple je pense que vous
connaissez la 27ème région qui a un
centre d'innovation en politique
publique et dont l'objectif est de et de
confronter quelque part alors ils
reprennent les les mots qui sont ceux
qui sont ceux du design donc ils ont un
prototype ils ont une idée
il le confronte à l'utilisateur final
généralement ils ont conscience que
l'utilisateur final n'est pas
l'utilisateur moyen parce que le
français n'existe pas mais il y a une
diversité donc ils vont rechercher cette
diversité pour s'assurer que le
prototype fonctionne
il le retravaille et ensuite une fois
que la chose fonctionne vraiment dans un
processus de design on peut on peut en
faire une politique et c'est vraiment
important parce que effectivement chaque
concepteur de politique publique et on
en est les premiers on a des idées
préconçues on a conscience d'un jeu de
contrainte qui peut donner une forme
spécifique à notre objet mais qui du
coup en fait fait que la personne en
face va pas pouvoir rentrer dans le
dispositif donc tous ces tous ces
dispositifs donc évaluation santé design
de politique publique c'est un peu les
deux piliers pour réussir à concevoir
des politiques qui ne loupent pas leur
cible
peut-être ajouter très rapidement que
dans notre groupe d'experts on avait
notamment les gens qui depuis ancré le
premier réseau des acteurs régionaux du
tiers financement de la rénovation
énergétique un réseau qui s'appelle
Séraphine donc on pourra vous mettre en
contact si besoin qui ont énormément de
d'éléments intéressants de retour
d'expérience sur la structuration des
différents outils financement en région
ce que ça donnait
sur le côté design de service des
politiques publiques je crois savoir que
la région Occitanie dans le
développement de son spire donc service
public intégré de la rénovation
énergétique ajustement fait appel à
cette méthode là pour essayer de coller
davantage aux besoins des usagers après
très concrètement par rapport au sujet
dont on parle aujourd'hui vous le savez
il y a mille-feuilles de dispositif de
réglementation
il y a globalement il y a deux façons de
gérer ça
soit en fait ce qu'on avait décidé avec
le DNT on dit on fusionne tout ça dans
une aide unique
mais on n'est pas sûr d'y arriver soit
on dit en fait on crée une interface qui
arrive à gérer cette complexité à la
place de ce qui veut dire enfin mettre
en place un guichet unique le guichet
unique pour pouvoir opérer il faut qu'il
fonctionne avec idéalement un portail
Unix c'est à dire qu'il faut le même
dossier afin de dossier unique d'aide
qui permet de combiner directement les
C2 ma prime rénov les aides régionales
etc voilà dans un même dossier de
candidature idéalement avec des critères
techniques harmonisés ce qui est pas le
cas aujourd'hui donc tout ça c'est des
choses qu'on pourrait arriver à faire
mais qui est encore une fois demande à
sortir des silos de gouvernance qu'on a
nous-mêmes créés parce qu'il y a
tellement d'acteurs qui travaillent sur
la question du logement
puisqu'on parle de ces politiques
publiques en silo et qui manque
cruellement de transversalité donc on a
auditionné il y a eu la création d'un
coordinateur
interministériel du plan de rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments donc je
voulais savoir c'est pour vous c'était
une première piste ou en tout cas qui
pouvait aller dans le bon sens et
comment vous voyez éventuellement son
rôle évolué
alors effectivement c'est une piste qui
va dans le bon sens puisque ce qu'on
pointe dans le rapport c'est un besoin
de coordination donc bien évidemment
toute
initiative de coordination et la
bienvenue on pourrait du coup avec ce
qu'on a dit sur la performance elle est
encore plus loin finalement c'est pas
peut-être pas une coordination de la
rénovation énergétique mais c'est une
coordination de la performance du
logement qu'on pourrait voir émerger ce
qui permettrait de faire dialoguer les
acteurs qui à leur actuel travaillent
sur le vieillissement sur l'adaptation
changement climatique sur l'énergie etc
et on pourrait imaginer quelque chose de
plus large ce serait à la fois plus
compliqué mais sans doute beaucoup plus
efficace pour pour réussir à
traiter toutes ces occasions manquées de
rénovation énergétique
quelque chose à avoir en tête c'est
qu'une occasion manquée de rénovation
énergétique elle se représentera pas
avant longtemps et donc du coup en terme
d'efficience de l'argent public investi
peut-être que que ça vaut le coup au
moment où on fait une intervention de
mettre un peu plus cher pour atteindre
le BBC par exemple sur une rénovation
urbaine mais on y revient pas plutôt que
de voir
déposer un isolant qui est pas assez
épais et remettre un isolant ou avoir
surdimensionné un générateur de
chauffage qui du coup va perdre en
performance donc effectivement il y a
sans doute un enjeu à penser la
performance de façon beaucoup plus large
et on aura sans doute pas mal
d'innovations qui peuvent sortir de là
si je peux me permettre pour compléter
le propos en termes de besoins de
coordination
en lien avec ce qu'on évoquait tout à
l'heure sur la structuration de l'offre
là où il y a une énorme besoins de
coordination c'est pour faire le lien
avec les questions d'industrialisation
aujourd'hui en France on parle de d'un
projet de loi pour l'industrie verte on
a la même chose au niveau européen on
parle de quoi on parle essentiellement
d'hydrogène de nucléaire peut-être un
peu de véhicules électriques de
renouvelables personne ne parle de
bâtiment et de renovation énergétique ce
qui est absolument hallucinant quand on
regarde les chiffres et qui vont et qui
vous ont été présentés tout à l'heure de
de besoin d'investissement additionnel
dans dans ces secteurs et également
quand on regarde que le secteur du
bâtiment et c'est lui qui a le plus fort
la plus forte intensité en termes
d'emploi par un million d'euros investis
une des plus fortes intensités en termes
de valeur ajoutée local et en même temps
[Musique]
des seuls secteurs qui n'a pas vu sa
productivité augmenter depuis des
décennies donc il y a un vrai besoin de
penser aujourd'hui les questions de
stratégie industrielle dans un secteur
qui part ailleurs présente des
potentiels d'innovation extrêmement
importants en termes de standardisation
de nouvelles solutions de tout ce qui
est préfabrication hors site
d'utilisation de maquettes numériques
enfin il y a quand même pas mal de
choses qui se passent et qu'on a du mal
à intégrer parce que le secteur est
considéré comme moins sexy que d'autres
sur le plan de l'innovation
merci beaucoup on vous remercie et on
vous souhaite une bonne soirée merci en
tout cas d'avoir participé à cette
audition nous avons fait partager vos
travaux à travers cette plateforme
d'experts merci bonne soirée